The Tragic Family Life of Kelsey Grammer
Dr. Crane was a recurring character in seasons
3 and 4 and went on to become a regular in
season 5 until the series finale in season
11.
The end of Cheers was not the end for Kelsey
Grammer, however.
He continued to portray Dr. Frasier Crane
as the star of the popular television series,
Frasier from 1993 – 2004.
Although his professional life has been very
successful, he has struggled in his personal
life and experienced more than his fair share
of tragedies.
Kelsey Grammer’s parents were divorced when
he was 2 years old and his father, Frank Grammer,
owned a coffee shop and a bar-and-grill called
Greer’s Place.
His mother brought Kelsey and Karen back to
her parents’ house in New Jersey where they
were raised by their mother and grandfather.
Unfortunately, his grandfather died when Kelsey
was 11.
On April 25, 1968, a man named Arthur B. Niles
set fire to Frank Grammer’s car outside
the St. Thomas home he shared with his second
wife, Elizabeth, and their four children (Betty,
John, Billy and Stephen).
When Frank Grammer went outside, Niles shot
him twice.
During the trial, Elizabeth Grammer testified
that she pulled her husband’s body from
in front of Niles’ car because he had threatened
to run over him as well.
Kelsey Grammer was only 13 years old at the
time of his father’s murder.
Niles was found not guilty of the murder by
reason of insanity and spent several decades
in a psychiatric ward.
In 1994, he was assessed to no longer be a
threat to society and was released.
In November of 2002, a judge issued a restraining
order against Niles which prevented him from
seeing his son.
In March 2003, Niles went back to prison after
pleading guilty to threatening to kill that
same judge- no longer a threat indeed.
Seven years later, when Kelsey was 20 years
old, his younger sister, 18 year old Karen
Grammer, was raped by four men and murdered
by Freddie Lee Glenn.
Glenn, who was a civilian worker at Fort Carson
near Colorado Springs, Colorado began his
involvement in a killing spree on June 19,
1975 when he, and two soldiers, including
Michael Corbett, decided to assault Daniel
Van Lone, a Four Seasons Hotel cook who had
just gotten off work at the time they grabbed
him.
They then took him to a secluded area to kill
Corbett shot him point blank in the head and
the trio made off with a whopping 50 cents
from the killing.
A little over a week later, Glenn and Corbett
met another Fort Carson soldier to sell some
pot to him.
Corbett had recently been training with bayonets,
and instead of making the sale, decided to
stab the soldier with a bayonet, supposedly
to see how it felt to stab someone.
On June 30, 1975, Karen Grammer was sitting
outside the Red Lobster in Colorado Springs,
Colorado, where she had just finished her
shift as a waitress.
Glenn, Corbett and two friends had decided
to rob the Red Lobster Karen worked at that
night but left the restaurant without any
money when they came across Karen.
They forced her into their car, stopped to
rob a convenience store, then drove her to
their apartment where they took turns raping
her for about four hours.
Afterwards, they put a cloth over her head,
promising to take her home.
They dumped her in a trailer park instead.
According to testimony during the trial, Glenn
had taken LSD and when he got out of the car,
he stabbed Karen in the back, on her hand
(presumably from her trying to shield herself),
and the neck.
He then drove away with his accomplices, leaving
her for dead.
Karen was made of sterner stuff, though, and
managed to crawl to the back porch of a nearby
home that had a light on.
Unfortunately, no one was at home.
Detectives describe a scene where Karen had
left bloody handprints and fingerprints where
she had tried to ring the doorbell.
From her fingerprints, she was inches away
from the doorbell when she passed out.
Although, given no one was home, ringing it
wouldn’t have done her any good, but of
course she didn’t know that.
She died on that back porch and was not found
until the next day.
Police did not know who the girl was for about
a week until Kelsey Grammer arrived and positively
identify her.
In 1976, Glenn was convicted for all three
murders and was sentenced to die via the gas
chamber.
However, in 1978, the Colorado Supreme Court
overturned the death penalty sentence.
Later, in a 2009 parole board hearing statement,
Kelsey stated, “She was so smart and good
and decent.
She wrote poetry … We could laugh for hours
together…
I was supposed to protect her — I could
not.
It very nearly destroyed me…
When we heard this man might be paroled, the
suffering began anew.”
Needless to say, his parole was not approved.
Glenn is eligible again for parole in 2014.
If that wasn’t all bad enough, five years
after Karen’s murder, on June 1, 1980, both
of Kelsey Grammer’s half brothers died unexpectedly.
Stephen and Billy were scuba diving off of
St. Thomas at the time.
When Billy failed to resurface, Stephen went
back in after him but died of a fatal embolism
during an improper ascent that followed.
Billy’s body was never recovered.
Kelsey Grammer’s good friend and the producer
of Frasier, David Angell, died in the September
11 terrorist attacks.
Angell and his wife, Lynn, were both passengers
of American Airlines Flight 11, the first
plane to hit the World Trade Center.